cash in on the family name because they
have no shame Republicans revealing
explosive new info on how the Biden Clan
hoovered up 10 million dollars in
foreign cash from places like China and
Romania Hunters set up over 20 companies
15 of which were done after dad became
VP top Republican James Comer also
identifying nine nine members of
President Biden's family who got some of
that dough including some grandkids not
Hunters love child unfortunately
while Vice President Biden was lecturing
Romania on anti-corruption policies in
reality he was a walking billboard for
his son and family to collect money for
years the leftist said no one is above
the law we'll put your money where your
mouth is Biden family needs to answer
for this and the doj needs to get off
its ass and investigate it's very hard
to come up with any legitimate business
reason to conduct transactions with this
type in this type of complex way this is
simply not how legitimate businesses
conducted I mean guys you in the press
this is easy pickings I'm giving you
Pulitzer stuff here the White House said
today that this was a political stunt
we're actually giving you a memorandum
with evidence
suffice to say and I love saying that
Joe's got some explaining to do and
answers like this aren't going to cut it
anymore
[Music]
that's not true all right so Jesse you
look at these businesses and they offer
no products or no Services remember they
always compared to Trump like their
business they were actual businesses but
there's no products no Services it's
just about hiding payments you could
like see a building that Trump built in
the sky with their own eyes Joe's like
the guy that's walking around with
cocaine all over his face and you're
like uh you got something right here and
he's like I've never touched the stuff
it's so obvious now and the left is
saying bribes are legal bribes are now
legal foreign Nationals they can't
donate to a politician's campaign
foreign Nationals can donate to a
politician's family and that's fine this
would be like Kamala Harris
being put in charge of immigration
flying her family to Mexico meeting with
a bunch of Mexican officials and then
having a bunch of corrupt Mexican
Nationals wire millions of dollars to
everybody in Kamala Harris's family and
then Kamala Harris's family trying to
hide it from the IRS and now the media
is saying they didn't link Joe Biden to
the Scandal really
Joe Biden isn't linked to the Biden
family bribe scandal at all really he
knows nothing about this then why do you
leave a voicemail for his son explaining
that he got away with it you know Whitey
fire the prosecutor you know why when he
becomes president he shuts down the FBI
China task force and then covers up the
lab league and then lets the balloon fly
across the country
why why why you want more yeah what else
do you want this guy is Australia okay
so all of this money can go into every
member of the Biden family bank accounts
but if a single dollar doesn't go into
Joe's checking account then it's clean
so you can just have foreign Nationals
bribing politicians families corrupt
ones
foreign Nationals convicted of bribery
bribing the Biden family but the media
says Joe's clean you have to be kidding
me the guy is a walking black male
operation the Department of Justice
knows the dirt the FBI knows the dirt
China has dirt on them the whole world
has dirt on the bidens the world has the
country by the bidens
all right Jessica uh I don't know how
you're going to respond to that but it
does show that Biden lied about the
Chinese the Chinese there was no Chinese
involvement and there was Millions there
so I think you're in quite a pickle if
you're going to try to defend this crime
family
it's a Biden crime family got him by the
bidens is good yes
um
so it was
I mean it was more exciting I guess than
your average James Comer interview you
know he got to a lot of people instead
of you know just being interviewed by
Ducey and kill me in the morning and
then pressing him and he was saying
Actually I don't even have anything and
I know last night you were like where
are the goods then at nine o'clock he
didn't have the goods they said wait for
9 A.M 9 A.M he didn't have the questions
Jessica I want the goods I want the
bidens the goods are a straight line
from Hunter Biden's business dealings or
any of the other nine that are listed
there were Joe Biden personally enriched
himself and to your point okay so let me
say something if the foreign National
pays Emma and Emma spends all of that
dirty foreign money on cars
on my child's are you saying that
college fund how is that any different
than what they're doing here okay so
let's try this just because it's my
personal bank account well first of all
Jill Biden is not being accused of
taking any money okay
his wife and his son's ex-wife and his
son's girlfriend a few things
why did the Romanians that's why you're
Joe Biden's granddaughter 25 000 I think
the audience deserves to know that
actually your points are easily
refutable so first of all your
granddaughter draw the Romanian real
estate Tycoon a crayon picture
so the New York Times looked into the
Romanian situation four years ago by the
way these are old stories oh yeah I
found no roles
I love the New York Times it's all good
built the paper of record and act like
it's not real The Wall Street Journal
which I think none of us the same ones
that said Trump colluded with Russia the
Wall Street journalists Wall Street
Journal in-house
looked into the China dealings no role
for Joe Biden then the Washington Post
one year ago
Hunter and his business partner to China
owned Air Force too they come back and
all of a sudden he's Rich lastly about
your point that the trumps they make all
these things I get it the shoe line
let's talk about Trump International
which was the most popular hotel when
Trump was in office and no one wanted to
go okay why did the Romanian money dry
up after Joe left the White House in
2016.
just like the Clinton Foundation yeah
that's another good one Clinton
Foundation let me simplify this Foster
good question
tonight at seven
let me simplify this for you
this is an organized criminal Enterprise
I've done this for 30 years okay this is
how they do it what you've got is the
Hallmarks of corruption
the accounts the LLCs the evasion and
the money laundering the partners come
in collect the foreign money and then
distribute it to an LLC to an LLC in
incremental amounts Joe Biden is the
front man Hunter Biden is The Bag Man
okay Joe Biden goes into foreign
countries lecturing them about
anti-corruption and he is representing
the freest greatest nation on Earth and
is wrapping himself in the flag of the
United States while his son is
collecting the money at the back door
this happened in Romania and this
happened in the Ukraine Joe Biden uses
his position as a vice president of the
United States to tell Ukraine to get the
prosecutor off the company where Hunter
is a member in making eighty thousand
dollars a month or he's going to
withhold our taxpayer money a million
dollars all right this is an appoint man
in energy and a point man on
anti-corruption and his son is right
behind him with the bags now let's talk
about why so many people are involved in
receiving the money so many people are
involved because you can't put that
money in one account right so we got the
one the what the daughter the husband
the sister-in-law that's why it's worked
out that way and why why did Paul
manafort spend years in solitary
confinement for being a uh a lobbyist in
a foreign country when this guy's been a
lobbyist in Ukraine in Romania in China
why is every dime that came out of China
connected to the Chinese intelligence or
the Chinese uh uh uh uh Communist party
and talk about it the the grandkids why
did Louis free the head of the FBI give
a hundred thousand dollars to Joe
Biden's granddaughter so he could go
into business with Hunter to reap the
money from the foreign country now let
me say one more thing I want to say one
more thing about this nobody's paying
taxes on this money I guarantee it so
you've got corruption foreign agents and
you've got taxes they got George Santos
and I don't care about him one way or
the other when a couple of months they
got him on 13 charges Hunter Biden five
and a half years they can't figure out
how to get him on a criminal charge this
is a corrupt family it's the Biden crime
family all right the great point about
the George Santos time frame yeah
compared so I just think there's just no
positive argument for them to make that
the president or the vice president or
members of his families received
millions of dollars from foreign
companies and it and if if your argument
is well there's no direct line to Joe
Biden's personal bank account that's
your defense yeah come on come on you do
better Jessica I thought you were gonna
have something else yeah I honestly did
I don't mean Jessica I mean that's
actually that's coming from the White
House Council Office and from their
lawyers I mean that's what that they're
saying that's like there's no direct
line to Joe Biden I'm like okay
that in your face in your face yeah in
your face I honestly feel great about
that you know what that's
a liberal Upper West Side cocktail
parties but not Europe I live downtown
it's embarrassing